hi I'm Simon n crow the 2010 to the sea
Geographic Bee I attend 8th grade at
Robert Ramaz bull no bridge right now I
am in a helping Kate Bethel Park which
was named after the first mayor of
Oakland jil think a pistol and behind me
is the friendship bell which was
developed in the joint project by the
city of oak ridge in several cities in
Japan to commemorate 50 years of
friendship from nineteen forty five to
nineteen ninety five since the end of
World War two between Japan and America
because oh why did they do this because
the whole bridge played a part in
developing the atomic bombs dropped on
hiroshima and nagasaki japan in august
mighty 45 old fridge was originally
built between 1942 in nitra 45 by the US
Army Corps of Engineers as a city for
the Manhattan Project which sought to
welcome Tomic bomb during World War two
they set up three sites in Oak Ridge
y-12 now the y-12 national security
complex that was to rent uranium by
using a device called a calutron k25
which had since been shut down and it's
now being demolished which was used to
enrich uranium by yes its diffusion and
x10 would now which has since become the
Oak Ridge National Laboratory one of the
foremost research laboratories in the
nation since then Oak Ridge has become a
citizen sister city of the city of
knockshee in Japan and the United States
and Japan have become close friends and
allies in nineteen nineteen ninety this
Bell was built in order to commemorate
that 50 years of that friendship I will
ring it any member of the public can do
with they come to oak ridge
you